yeah
and it was enhanced by making solid eye
contact with you
you know that if an english person
maintains eye contact with you for five
seconds while drinking tea
you turn english
either that or i own your country i
don't know which one happens
we'll get five suggestions and then
we'll drop a b and into a freestyle wrap
where is our first suggestion coming
from on this side of the room there's a
hand up here so polite yes
a day in the life of a moyle a moyle is
someone who chops foreskins off right
you impressed when i knew that word yeah
you thought you were going to catch me
you thought i only knew like rabbi
rabbi dick chopper
if your name was rabbi richard chopper
that'd be pretty
disappointment
disappointment
or team-based disappointment or in
general
in general in general disappointment in
general correct in general
middle of the room
bisexuals cool
um
that is a sexuality not glasses that let
you see near and far away
what um are you yourself bisexual
and what what about bisexuality or
bisexualism that's not all words
like bisexualism would you like to focus
on iraq
i don't know no one believes this that's
true yeah yeah yeah bioranger is what
it's called right which is uh that um
okay cool people who don't believe
bisexuals exist
people in this
area what do you like about
abortion
so far um
we've got disappointment we've got
bisexuals not existing we've got
abortion
last last suggestion guys and you've got
you've got a high standard
squeegee
yeah that's good so a squeegee in in
british pilots is the
kind of thing that you scrape to like
you know get water off shower walls and
stuff that's what it is over here right
that's cool that we share some things
right
you probably spell it without the u like
a brick right
s-e-e-g-e-e
okay cool this is uh this is this t-is
almost finished i need to neck that
otherwise there's gonna be too cold by
the time the rat finishes but this is uh
it's going to be a freestyle that's a
wrap made up on the spot based entirely
on those suggestions the suggestions are
morals disappointment
bisexuals not existing abortions and
squeegees
and um i don't want you guys to worry
because it's not going to be as
toe-curlingly
bad as you're expecting a privately
educated middle-class white british boy
to be
so i'll drop this beat for you and we'll
have some absolute fun it's
comic coming to the stage harry's
gliding on it i just got you and some of
your ilk you were walking on stage with
the tea and the milk and you didn't even
use the full of the jug hopefully we set
it off hopefully it's enough and you
will enjoy the show or release my
portion anyway bro never tell a girl to
get abortion unless she wants it that's
her own choice people say it's my body
my advice and if you want abortion down
in texas well you better be quick better
check first you're like before six weeks
or five and a half and if you're not do
it yourself in the bubble bar really
sorry involving that anger i'm just
saying you can grab a coat hanger no
don't do that you'll damage it inside go
to oklahoma the clinics that provide
they will help you they will get you
unfilled if it's after 10 weeks you
can't use a pill that's a medical one
it's absurd you only gotta get inside
and be so surgical i hope that you
enjoyed the abortion instruction you did
if you're democrat but not republican
give a shout there like this
[Music]
i'm just like what is even that blade ah
you look lazy sir he's just coming with
gillette razor
how does this even chop off the tip if
you slip then my son will end up with no
not a thing dick i want to inflict on
anyone whether they're not or a jew so
take care don't give it a miss where
does the moral do is [ __ ] yeah uh briss
i know those words several of you didn't
you were like our chris we'd be really
hidden we're gonna get away the blood
from the bad circumcision kind of clean
it up by using all the surgical
precision with the squeegee
use the squeegee otherwise the mildew
starts to accumulate
like bisexuals do they exist no one even
knows people say pick a side do you like
girls or the bros that's not a problem
you can respect them i think we all
agree it's a spectrum it's your
sexuality quivers on a tuesday and at
the weekend
you say like i don't even care i'm just
desperate for a [ __ ] i'd be walking in
the club i'm picking you up i'm like ah
anyone who catches my eye i'll [ __ ] all
of you here probably this guy
[Applause]